>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
HOW ABOUT THIS AS A MENTAL
EXERCISE.
TRY REMEMBER BACK TO THE
YEAR 2009.
IT WAS ONLY A DECADE AGO BUT
IT FEELS LIKE A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT ERA AND ENEMY WAYS
IT WAS.
IN 2009, MOST PEOPLE DIDN'T
HAVE SMART PHONES.
LATE NIGHT TELEVISION WAS
STILL FUNNY.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WAS
STILL PRETENDING TO PUT THE
INTEREST OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS ABOVE THOSE OF THE
REST OF THE WORLD IN
SEPTEMBER OF 2009 PRESIDENT
OBAMA GAVE A SPEECH ABOUT
HEALTHCARE TO GIANT SESSION
OF CONGRESS.
YOU MAY REMEMBER IT.
ONE OF OBAMA'S MOST EMPHATIC
PROMISES IN THAT SPEECH AND
IN FACT DURING THAT WHOLE
SEASON WAS THAT FOREIGNERS
LIVING IN OUR COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY WOULD NEVER
RECEIVE BENEFITS UNDER HIS
PLAN.
HE SAID THAT REPEATEDLY BUT
NOT HERB BELIEVED HIM.
>> ALWAYS THOSE THAT CLAIMED
REFORM EFFORTS WOULD INCLUDE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THIS TOO IS FALSE.
THE REFORMS I'M PROPOSING
WOULD NOT APPLY TO THOSE
HERE ILLEGALLY.
>> YOU LIE.
>> NOT TRUE.
>> YOU LIE YELLED SOMEONE IN
THE ROOM.
THAT MAN WAS CONGRESSMAN JOE
WILSON OF SOUTH CAROLINA.
FOR THE CRIME OF BEING RUDE
TO SAINT OBAMA WILSON WAS
INSTANTLY DENOWPSED BY HIS
FELLOW REPUBLICANS, TOTALLY
DISRESPECTFUL HUFFED JOHN
MCCAIN WHO HIMSELF SPENT
DECADES YELLING OBSCENITIES
OF PEOPLE ON CAPITOL HILL.
JIMMY CARTER CALLED WILSON A
RACIST.
AND YET IT TURNS OUT THAT
JOE WILSON WAS RIGHT.
A DECADE LATER THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS
ABANDONED ANY PRETENSE THAT
AMERICA EXISTS TO BENEFIT
AMERICANS.
THEY TELL US OUR COUNTRY IS
INNATELY EVIL CONCEIVED IN
RACISM FOR THE PURPOSE OF
OPPRESSION.
WE ARE A SINFUL NATION AND
TO REDEEM OURSELVES WE MUST
SACRIFICE FOR THE WORLD'S
POOR.
AMONG MANY, MANY OTHER
THINGS.
THIS MEANS PAYING THE
HEALTHCARE BILLS OF FOREIGN
NATIONALS WHO HAVE NO RIGHT
TO BE HERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
WATCH JOE BIDEN EXPLAIN.
>> LOOK, I THINK THAT ANYONE
WHO IS IN A SITUATION WHERE
THEY ARE IN NEED OF
HEALTHCARE, REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THEY ARE DOCUMENTED
OR UNDOCUMENTED, WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO SEE THEY ARE
CARED FOR.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED MORE
CLINICS AROUND THE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: WHETHER THEY HAVE
DOCUMENTS OR NOT, THIS ISN'T
A FRINGE CANDIDATE YOU SAW
MIKE GRAVEL OR SOME GREEN
PARTY WACKO THAT'S THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
NOW THE FRONTRUNNER FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION.
AS OF TONIGHT JOE BIDEN IS
UP BY 25 POINTS OVER THE
REST OF THE FIELD.
TWO YEARS FROM NOW BIDEN
COULD EASILY BE PRESIDENT.
CHANCES ARE HIS RUNNING MATE
WOULD BE SENATOR KAMALA
HARRIS OF CALIFORNIA AND
OVER THE WEEKEND HARRIS MADE
IT OFFICIAL SHE AGREES WITH
JOE BIDEN ON THIS QUESTION.
ILLEGAL ALIENS DESERVE FULL
GOVERNMENT HEALTHCARE.
WATCH.
>> SO YOU SUPPORT GIVING
UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE,
MEDICARE FOR ALL FOR PEOPLE
IN THIS COUNTRY HE WILL
IN THIS COUNTRY IE WILL
IN THIS COUNTRY ILLWILL
IN THIS COUNTRY ILLEGLL
IN THIS COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
>> LET ME BE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT, THIS I'M OPPOSED TO
ANY POLICY THAT WOULD DENY
IN OUR COUNTRY ANY HUMAN
BEING FROM ACCESS TO PUBLIC
SAFETY, PUBLIC EDUCATION, OR
PUBLIC HEALTH, PERIOD.
>> Tucker: LET ME BE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT THIS.
SO YOU KNOW YOU ARE NOT
TAKING HER OUT OF CONTEXT.
WE EVEN GOT THE HAND
GESTURES.
SHE IS TELLING US THAT WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO PAY
THE MEDICAL BILLS OF EVERY
ILLEGAL ALIEN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
PERIOD.
AS SHE SAID.
NOW, HOW MANY PEOPLE WOULD
THAT BE, EXACTLY?
WELL, WE DON'T KNOW.
IN FACT, WE HAVE NO IDEA.
THANKS TO LOBBYING FROM
ELECTED DEMOCRATS LIKE
KAMALA HARRIS, NOBODY KNOWS
HOW MANY ILLEGAL ALIENS LIVE
IN THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
COULD BE 12 MILLION.
COULD BE 40 MILLION.
ONE THING IS FOR SURE ONCE
THE REST OF THE WORLD KNOWS
THAT WE ARE PASSING OUT FREE
HEALTHCARE THERE WILL THERE
WILL SOON BE MANY, MANY
MORE.
HOW MUCH WILL THAT COST OUR
COUNTRY.
WHO WILL PAY FOR IT.
HOW MANY MORE DOCTORS AND
NURSE ALSO WE NEED TO
PROVIDE THAT HEALTHCARE?
HOW MANY MORE HOSPITALS AND
CLINICS WILL WE HAVE TO
BUILD.
JOE BIDEN SAYS WE HAVE TO
BUILD SOME.
HOW MANY?
NO ONE IS SAYING.
NO ONE IS SAYING ANYTHING
PRECISELY ABOUT IT.
THEY HAVEN'T THOUGHT ABOUT
THE DETAILS.
THAT'S ODD.
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IS
ALREADY OVERPRICED AND
INADEQUATE.
IN FACT, THAT'S THE MAIN
REASON DEMOCRATS WON IN THE
LAST ELECTION BECAUSE THEY
PROMISED TO MAKE IT BETTER.
NOW THEY ARE TELLING US THE
SOLUTION, THE WAY THEY ARE
GOING TO MAKE IT BETTER IS
BY GIVING UNLIMITED FREE
MEDICAL CARE TO FOREIGNERS
WHO BREAK OUR LAWS.
THAT'S JUST LUNANCY.
THERE IS NO OTHER WAY TO PUT
IT.
OF COURSE, IT'S GETTING
VIRTUALLY NO COVERAGE.
THE MEDIA HAVE NO INTEREST
IN TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT MIGHT EMBARRASS THEIR
PARTY.